hello youtubers up next cosmic queries
star talk the worlds between planets and
stars
[Music]
this is star talk i'm your host neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today we're going to
have a cosmic queries edition
of star talk with my co-host chuck
knight
yes baby hey neil all right what's
happening between us here
that's right i got my friend and
colleague yes not only professional
colleague but museum colleague jackie
faraday that's right
in the house in two houses
double house double house uh jackie
is one of the world's experts on the
the worlds that exist between planets
and stars wow
there's not a sharp boundary there you
might have thought so or maybe you never
thought about it
she's thought about it yes and she and
her her peeps
she's got a whole community of people in
fact
after we hired her she brought other
people after she came
so this place the american museum of
natural history right is one of the
intellectual centers
of this subject because of this woman
right here that's correct that's
that one no no i'm gonna take ownership
of that you sure
yeah we actually have a our research
group has
uh stickers and t-shirts and logo we
have a logo
uh and
because our subway symbols in new york
city are circles
yes with letters inside yes they are so
what are what is what's your design
there so we are
bd nyc oh stands for brown dwarfs
right in new york city research group
plus the b train stops at this it
certainly does
that's correct b and c there you go so
so we've got
uh we solicited questions from from our
fan base telling them we're going to
have the world's expert on this
sort of nether world between planets and
stars yes and
came hundreds of questions hundreds yes
hundreds hundreds of questions yes
you've got them and i've got
neither of us have seen it no you
haven't and it's not that it's a test no
no i love shows like this when i have
one of my
my astrophysics colleagues because then
i'll have to say a thing
right she knows everything i'll just i'm
gonna go get lunch and then you you tell
me when you're done
right so i like that neil saying i know
everything
that's a nice that's a nice compliment
thank you yeah
all right well listen why don't we jump
into it with our first question which is
always from a patreon patron okay here
we go this
is amz industries wow we've gone
corporate with patreon patrons
amz industries new york stock exchange
list tell me about it
amc right um amz says
um the sun is the biggest star in our
solar system
i believe it's also the only star in our
solar system keep going
okay yeah maybe i'm wrong i'm going to
say that one yeah okay
do we know a star or any other object in
space or interstellar space that is
bigger than our sun okay
uh okay so just see it's they just mixed
galaxy with solar system that's
what they did that's thank you yes i'm
trying to figure this out but you got it
that's what they did so uh um
also to jackie um do you believe in
zodiac signs
uh huh okay all right
uh okay twofold question both of which
are interesting to answer
and they both sound completely unrelated
to each other
well i i think i believe i think one is
a genuine interest in the cosmos and
they
and the other is a genuine interest in
you
i love it so i will go with the first
one is the
sun in our okay so yes it's the only
star that we know of in our solar system
although we have searched for another
object
that might be maybe not a star but one
of these objects i study a brown dwarf
brown dwarf that might be a companion to
our own sun since it's alone it's by
itself it doesn't have a partner
so you're warming really far away yeah i
was going to say because you're talking
what i believe we're talking about to
tell me if i'm wrong
is that sometimes there are anomalies
in the gravitational movement of
objects in our neighborhood right
so i think you're going with the planet
nine explanations okay that's what
it is yeah and that's also been been
pulled on
and is very popular right now not pluto
just to be clear right right yeah we
gotta be clear that's right
and also we can discuss why that word
planet's not very good in this context
anyway right
so an object outside of what's currently
pluto's position that might be tugging
on
another in the outer part of the solar
system the kuiper belt which is this
this this area of things that are left
over from when the solar system formed
uh and whether or not there's something
else that's well beyond that
possibly there's indications theorists
certainly think that
um but um but there was this nemesis
hypothesis that existed several
several years ago for which that
possibly you could
link up mass extinctions that happened
on this planet
with a highly eccentric other object
that might have been orbit is eccentric
right yes orbit is eccentric
not emotionally eccentric it could have
been right
although it does spend a lot of time
alone so maybe you never know why are we
giving emotions to the objects
part of the problem people put so much
emotion
on these objects they want to feel them
yeah yeah
you just call the thing eccentric yes
eccentric right so
so that it would have an eccentric orbit
uh and that
possibly was every time it got into some
area of the outer solar system it would
kick a bunch of stuff
in uh towards the uh towards our area
and cause possibly mass extinction
comets that would then hit yeah yeah
comets uh
asteroids um and so that's that's
basically we've looked
far and near and we haven't found
anything gotcha so possibly that's out
um so nemesis was the proposed name if
such an object existed
and that would have been its name had we
found it yeah and nemesis is the idea
that it's
our nemesis right the earth's nemesis
not necessarily the sun's
right the earth's because if it's gonna
uh it's launching
[Laughter]
why would you want that right that would
feel like your nemesis
right sure sure so that okay so beyond
that the question is asking if there's a
um a star that's bigger than our our own
son and that's like
yeah definitely there's so many my
favorite star in this the nighttime sky
is called ada karina
aydah karina you know ada karina aydah
korean love me some ada
and i love the fact that it actually
sounds like a pop star you know what i
mean
yeah yeah yeah it's in the constellation
karina
uh that makes a good ice cream flavor
that ate a korean [ __ ]
no i i ate a korean karina is the name
of the flavor
wow i wouldn't have put that in there
but okay all right
oh my god it's in the homunculus nebula
can you make that
like the homunculus nuts that somehow
somebody could make that you put on the
ice cream
well so ada karina is a very large star
um
we now think that it's actually two
stars a binary star system
uh we call it a luminous blue variable
it's this object that's very
very massive and so we think it's two
and so forty to fifty times the mass of
our our own
sun but probably two of them they go
around each other eclipsing each other
so that you can actually see the light
of one dip
very very periodically that's a
variability you were talking about yeah
yeah so let me just ask you this uh even
though
it's a body moving in front or
transiting another body
how is one slightly larger than the
other
because we're they're both luminous yeah
so the idea of a transit is one blocks
light from the other but if they're both
glowing what are you measuring so
they're not the exact same mass
okay uh so you'd have one that's say 60
times the mass of the sun
and the other is 30 times the mass okay
there's even some
hypothesis that there's a triple system
in there there's three not just two
wow so i'm noting ada karina because i
think it is
just an awesome star uh or star system
but that's good photos of that right oh
yeah
you check that out yeah we might put one
on the website here yeah you should
cool because it was part of an hst
legacy project
space telescope sorry hubble space
telescope yes we'll apologize
yeah you're right in the lingo girl i'm
in the lingo do the lingo thing
hst and elementalp right okay
thank you neil um and it it's a uh so
there's there's a lot of data on
and on adarina uh but it's not the most
massive you get even more massive
there's 100 200 times the mass of our
own sun wow and these are
not stable systems this is these again
we're not referring to their motions
right exactly stars and unstable stars
i like where this is going we actually
have degenerate stars as well that's
another thing
really yes it's an actual kind of stuff
is that
okay i i can't even tell you forget it
i just my mind immediately went to a
start just for constellation weenies out
there
uh carina is a constellation visible
primarily in the southern hemisphere and
it's part of
the constant it's part of a much larger
constellation that used to be one
piece and it's the the ship of
uh the argonauts okay argo novice is the
ship
and it's just it i queen is this is the
is the keel
i think the keel yeah yeah so what they
did was that that concept was way too
big for
britches so they broke it up into parts
there's a compass there's a sail
there's the hull there's the there and
so this is it is
the ata if brightest right
object in the constellation karina so
alpha beta gamma
delta epsilon zeta eta so it'll be the
seventh brightest
star and that's important also because
it's not always the ada
because that's what it was cataloged at
but at one time it was one of the
brightest stars in the nighttime sky
because the thing is going through
massive and insane explosions
and it's just dumping material off which
is creating
that makes the beautiful photos yes the
nebula that's around it
is so unbelievably attractive to look at
and that's just from the truck is really
cool
yeah it's really a crime scene right
you're gonna see this gas just
spilling out so something happened down
in there yeah something bad
happened and something is continually
bad happening
i mean i would love to fly close and
have a look at that thing
and you wouldn't want to be closed as a
human because there's probably a lot of
really bad radiation around there but
man would it be a sight
because it is really pretty that's very
cool
human eye so aydah karina yeah well so
the sun is large enough if you hollowed
it out
right you could pour a million earths
into it our sun
our sun right and now we're told my star
is bigger than that
and so these these super massive stars
these are
these are the ones that become black
holes like our sun couldn't become a
black hole
nobody no our sun couldn't become a
black hole not massive enough but these
are
these are the ones like you look at
these stars luminous blue variables and
then there's another kind they're called
wolf rayet stars
so there's actually somebody here
rayette yes
yes actually debatable if it's wolf red
well these are two people
oh is that the deal so the people did
they discovered this well they first
studied
them in an important way all right and
so then realize that no other stars look
like those do so they became their own
category
nice wolf what were you at r-a-y-e-t
okay in french you believe
you don't pronounce the trailing
consonant right nice
all right and for the second question uh
re-read that
which is do you believe in zodiac signs
uh so what i
i believe is such an interesting thing
there are constellations
in the nighttime sky which are the
markers for where the
ecliptic of the path that the sun takes
and the sky and all the planets and
the moon they take and so those are
designations in the sky and that is
it's where the the um the sun and the
planets and the moon all move
yeah i don't place any significance on
um
what people like to do in reading their
astrological
uh sign i'm actually not even sure what
my sign is
oh wow um when were you born not totally
true i do know what it is but
okay but you don't think about it okay
don't think about it
right mine is cancer i'm a festering
malignancy
thank you does it feel accurate
oh man all right all right
enough of that jackie yeah that was
great wow
i got so much out of that man what else
you got there all right why don't we um
let's see how about um
this is uh sherman from san diego
says are we still on the patreon this is
a patreon page okay
sherman from san diego sherman says uh
hi
dr tyson and hi dr fahrity understanding
that it's only been a few decades since
the discovery of the first
exoplanet there is still a lot we don't
know about even the closest ones to
our solar system what tools and or
resources are needed
in the works or in the works to help us
better understand
the nature and composition of these
objects
so that's a very good question um
is there is there anything new and
exciting
that question by asking you are your
methods and tools
to find the worlds between planets and
stars do you have
overlap with the methods and tools of
those who are finding planets
yeah and i actually think this would
drive the question
of what do we mean when we say the word
planet in this particular instance
because the objects that i study that
are
that i get the most excited about
studying are ones that we
sometimes refer to as rogue worlds as
they are the same mass
as the objects that others might want to
call a planet those objects orbit a star
and the ones that i studied don't orbit
a star they're in between
yeah they just they're off there they're
alone they have no host star
homeless there's nothing they're
homeless yeah we call morphin
to be nicer maybe wow
the orphaned objects that are out there
so that what i do because
it's a lot easier for you to attempt to
get to what's in the atmospheres of
these objects
when they don't have a host star that
you have to block the light of because
the contrast ratio is so large i haven't
thought about that
it's so much like like seeing a firefly
in a hollywood
searchlight you can't the brightness
contrast is so
high you can't see the dim things so you
got objects where there's no main star
so it's just the opposite it's good just
it on its own
but this is where it gets controversial
right because
it could be the exact same mass
temperature
gravity the whole deal that we would
call an
object around another star but because
we find it alone
we call them brown dwarfs and when
they're the lowest mass
so not getting too far down this rabbit
hole which i assume you want me to
define what a brown dwarf is at some
point yeah
probably important for your audience to
understand what i'm an expert in
but just quickly you're saying that
location
matters in how you classify such an
object
we don't have a good running definition
right now
for what it is that we'll call this high
mass end problem
outside of our own solar system high
mass planet high mass planet high mass
uh so planet or so what's a brown
so brown dwarfs are these objects that
exist in mass in between stars and
planets
or whatever the gray area in between
and the idea being that when you form a
star you have a giant molecular cloud of
hydrogen
and it fragments into pieces whatever
causes the fragmentation the compression
of the gas it it breaks off into pieces
the smallest possible pieces that could
fragment off wait wait so you have the
main piece that's the main star
well it for lots of pieces right like
but one of them is gonna
the big one is gonna be the star there
could be hundreds of them that'll be
stars yeah of course all right
so now you've got the other bits and
pieces go on yeah so there'll be a whole
spectrum a whole distribution of objects
that will break off out of a gigantic
molecular cloud
and this molecular cloud will break down
into once you compress it
so that all of the gas then gets pushed
together and then
uh enough so that the pressure there
ignites the cores
of these things that break off into tiny
pieces the
smallest of the pieces end up being
these objects that don't even know
that they don't have enough mass to get
the core
hot enough to get nuclear burning going
but they do it anyway
no no this is they think they're going
to be a star but they're not
so whatever now you guys are putting a
motion on it don't know what they should
or shouldn't be they're just existing
and so this this is why people call them
failed stars
because they're not getting enough mass
but i look at it and like whatever dude
like who cares
it is existing with not enough mass
that's fine
it doesn't have the mass instead it
can't get that nuclear engine going
that's at the center of our sun
instead it's like a coal plucked from a
fire it just
cools through its life and that's it and
that is in between
basically what we say is the top mass
for that that it happens is 75 times the
mass of the jupiter
75 jupiter that would be a star that's
above that
right exactly and this is very
metallicity dependent like how much
how much metal is it how many how many
times what's medalist oh okay
yeah yeah heavy at the core like okay
so how much of that was available will
change like how much mass you need to
get the core burning
but then uh the lower end of it the low
end
i don't know what's the lowest mass
fragment that you can break off this is
a huge discussion in astronomy right now
what is the lowest mass piece that
breaks off and still becomes a thing
and it is a thing that right all right
that thing that doesn't know what it is
wait one last thing on it one last thing
because i know we have to stop but
the planet would be opposite end of this
can you form an object the planets form
in a disk
around a star but how big can it get
around a star so now you've got two
competing things
you've got objects that form by breaking
up a cloud that then
self fragments and blah blah blah blah
and then you've got a disk
around a forming star and how big can
that object get
oh wow okay planet version take a quick
break
so that's the brown dwarf establishment
right there
as opposed to my brown dwarf which was
uh the dwarf that was never painted by
disney because he was racist
the eighth dwarf yes chuck has issues
with getting them through
when we come back more with jackie
ferrity on the worlds between planets
and stars
on star talk we're big fans of
storyblocks here at star talk
we have a small team that puts together
your favorite show and we use
storyblocks unlimited plan
to get more 4k stock footage than we
know what to do with
i mean really they even have footage of
a monkey on a rope
and a gorilla with a piggy bank and
that's the same gorilla
with a pizza they've also got loads of
audio and video too it's royalty free so
you can use it anywhere
create like a pro with story blocks
swing on over to the description to
learn more
see what it did there that's
storyblocks.com
star talk we're back star talk cosmic
queries
the worlds between stars and planets
where are they what are they we got a
word for them
but do we understand them and our best
chance of understanding them
is this woman right here yes jackie
faraday in the house
yes friend and colleague in the
department of astrophysics right here
at the american museum of natural
history and you just went you just
described something i hadn't fully
appreciated just before the break
that you have this humongo gas cloud
a molecular cloud they call them and
it'll break into
bits and these are typically stars but
some might not be stars
in addition to that each one of these
will have a disc of material
surrounding it that will then break up
into little bits beyond
the bits that just broke off to make the
thing that had the disc
did i did i understand that you're doing
good yeah yeah i will say
right so though so two dynamic two
different kinds of phenomenon going on
two different formation mechanisms
that's the phrase i'm looking for right
and so we want to use that as
definitional
for saying like what kind of object are
you looking at i'd prefer to know how it
formed
because can you eject these objects that
form around a star yeah you do
oh a hundred percent you do yeah they're
launched off we probably we ejected
stuff all sorts of ways
we might have like 30 planets or
something right yes
exactly and now we're down to eight get
over it
um and so all those would be rogue
planets by now rogue
rogue worlds i like rogue worlds rather
than planets or could have any of them
become joined forces to become like get
picked up by another
yeah get picked up by another star yeah
so we talk about that too that's pretty
hard to do but
not impossible okay it's possible that
it could happen
uh they could also they get scattered
around and we have evidence
for this material now like present day
we have material that has
passed through our own solar system
after it probably got ejected from a
totally different solar system
this object called oh muammua which is a
interstellar asteroid right rock that
came flying through here and that
probably got
dumped out when uh its own sun was
forming its solar system
so the one thing on this that's right
that ain't right i know
yeah this is okay like don't let the
doorknob hit you
but don't you think by the way it's
hawaiian for scout
and it's repeated for emphasis so that's
it's basically first scout and it was
named that because it was on a
tells it was found through a telescope
in hawaii the pan stars telescope which
is a wonderful telescope and
uh as an homage to hawaii
they chose this one language yeah right
so so
just i i did this calculation long ago
this is a perfect time for me to
invoke it all right because how often
does one here make vocal calculations
if there were four bumble bees flying
in the continental united states okay
the chances of them accidentally bumping
into each other
are greater than any two stars
in our galaxy i have a response to this
wait wow
so but if you want to talk about how
empty space is because that's how much
stuff is not there it's not there if you
have rogue
things cast off there's still the
unlikelihood
that you would even come into the
vicinity of another star but even if you
did
you can have a velocity that's hard to
trap supposedly so
um had hyperbolic velocity so we're not
right it's coming through and it's
coming
through it's not even looking back right
now right it has nothing gangbusters
right like we didn't capture it we're
not doing anything we're not doing a
damn thing
it just it came through like beep beep
here i come
there i go and even looking at its
motion uh
its velocity yeah it looked like maybe
we were its first pass
possibly this is very hard to tease out
but there was a paper on that whether or
not we were the first research paper
a research paper that was looking at
whether or not we were its first
encounter
after it departed and we traced we
looked astronomers tried to trace it
back and see where it might have
come from right so now with that in mind
did where the first pass did we
alter its course oh great question yeah
uh i don't know maybe probably a little
bit oh yeah yeah yeah
it feels good yeah you can you can you
can you you cannot get captured but
still feel what's going on here
okay oh yeah yeah so if you if you look
at they have the the trajectory oh yeah
yeah yeah and the trajectories are
right in response to the gravity of
jupiter in the sun
but when you primarily put enough of a
change in the velocity that when it gets
to the next star
it's really obvious like oh this is its
next stellar encounter
i'm not sure we can tease it out quite
yet because it still looks like a dis
it's like a disc object just sort of
flying around in the disk of the milky
way
nice um wait wait wait wait wait wait on
this
this is important because neil you want
to take a tv show
no the jetsons oh flying uh the flying
cars yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i thought you were doing bp it's before
your time sorry
maybe she's like okay the objections
were so before
everybody's time i watched it when i was
a kid
so i don't know why it's because the
roadrunner did a beep beep too yes he
did yeah you don't just learn recently
this had nothing to do with anything the
roadrunner
never left the road how about when he
was standing on air and the coyote would
fall
no the coyote's standing on air
roadrunner isn't that's true
oh huh interesting yeah rona stops
before it gets to the edge of the cliff
and it's always on the road that's
interesting hence the roadrunner yeah
i have another point on stellar flight i
want to just
pull us back in here um you might like
my pop culture references
i love it i love it i love it i love it
so great um but
the one of the things that i think is
massively
uh interesting right now in astronomy
is how many times stars
not run into each other but interact
with one ano one another
so the issue of and this is this is my
new thing
i'm really in to the new villain of
planetary architecture
is the stellar flyby the unappreciated
um influence that stars that move by
each other can have and the reason why i
say that
fly by looting flybys that
will change the court the change the
structure of maybe your planetary system
or now like okay so the question i think
had something to do with what we're
understanding about exoplanets and and
learning about it in the future
so here's one for everybody in one
million years
just about one million it's like 1.1
million years okay let me put that on my
um
put it on the calendar october 12th
october 12th one million years
plus or minus like 10 000 years yes but
um
but there will be a stellar flyby so
at its closest encounter by a star
that's
smaller than our own sun but we're
headed for each other
and in one million years it's going to
pass within our oort cloud
it's coming straight in to the orc cloud
the outer region of comets
that's a spherical zone very distant but
very there
very there lots of material yeah this is
like
trillions of comets just okay that's
just
waiting to strike i was gonna say that
sounds catastrophic
[Music]
[Laughter]
astronomers have looked at it to see
like is the dent
you know is it going to be a disaster uh
and the conclusion is
it's uncertain but the impact that it'll
have on the org cloud might not be super
bad
however jan ort was the dutch astronomer
who first calculated the existence of
the ore cloud it's so far away you can't
see the objects that
at that distance but when they come in
you see them near the sun and you look
at their
trajectory they say oh this might
terminate way
out at this distance before it comes
back again the calls are coming from
inside the house
so if you think about it the oort cloud
actually stretches a third of the way
to the closest star a third of the way
it gets loose so i mean think about that
you know i mean you get something that
flies between
us and that ah that next closest object
it
loosens up things because they've only
barely held on to begin with so any any
disturbance will completely right wreak
havoc
and most important here is the
consideration of we're constantly doing
mission planning like what are the next
stages of mission planning right
what's the what's the name of this star
just right now so i it's gliese 78780
okay it's a it's one of these names that
um
i constantly mix it with 780 versus 781
i think so that's my fear
not gleason g-l-e-i-s-e
yes g-l-i-e-s-e
e-s-e it's a catalog of uh with
high moving fast moving stars right
close bright
so they're mostly fast-moving yeah yeah
they're fast-moving
uh in our field of view so in order for
that to be the case they have to be
nearby
so man i was hoping it was gleason no
no but just to be clear
so this is not a catalog of stars that
are actually moving fast
it's a catalog of stars that are moving
fast in our field of view
so you can have a bird fly by in front
of you
and that's going maybe 20 miles an hour
and a plane that's moving
past your field of view much more slowly
and you're not going to say
that the bird is the bird the bird is
not going 600 miles an hour right
right so that angle matters and that
angle
it manifests by its distance so uh
there's a catalog
of selected for their
for their fast movement in our night sky
and those tend to be the nearest objects
yeah right because and so that one
had been known we've known about that
star for a really long time it's a
bright it's a very bright star and it's
it's it's it's headed for us we are
headed for it it's heading for us and
just think about it
it's probably got a solar system
around it and a northwest why not
they're probably the majority of stars
why wouldn't they
happen and so when you think i've got
all of my every time i give a science
wave but don't you wanna we'll we're
gonna see it totally want to get in it
like people bring it here wait that
means our clouds will intersect
more than that yes the oracle clouds the
kuiper belts possibly like whatev
whatever this thing's got around it
we could fly something to it there's a
lot of this discussion about going to
proxima centauri because we all want to
get there like now
yeah yeah glee 780 man let's go that's
gonna be even closer when it's close
right it's gonna be so close
she sounds like she's like ready to i
was gonna say and i am so ready to do
this one million years ago
you got her telescope all ready for us
this is very sad because you better take
them longevity pills before
that happens no by then we'll be able to
upload your consciousness to a computer
so you'll still be around that's good
yeah i'd like to see it when it happens
cool chuck what else you got all right
so
okay this is let's go for a quick one
because i know we're running out of time
in this segment this is from rossi king
you can do a long one and then i tease
the next segment dude this is how i do
this well you know if we keep discussing
this like this we'll be
able to do it with this shirt go
no this is rossy king from youtube uh
actually i just wanted to ask this for
myself too
was jupiter a failed star and then the
person says
i'm really glad it failed because i love
it in the night time
that should be a quick answer yeah but
it's super it feels so which
you know yeah yeah no uh uh it's not
no the quick answer to that would be no
but again let's not call them failed
stars
let's just call them achieving planets
i call them over-excited planets thank
you
for achieving planets i'm not kidding
neil this is like
terrorists this is a very modern teacher
lingo right for
excited planets that's what i sometimes
call them but then i don't like don't
star-shame me
don't star-shame me you guys are going
with it exactly
exactly jupiter shouldn't feel any in
any way shape or form like inadequate
exactly
right it is a behemoth of our solar
system
many times i say if i'm gonna find an
earth-like planet uh
that i'll be comfortable saying yes
let's let's consider that habitable i
want a jupiter at a jupiter radius away
because you know what jupiter does for
us
it protects us in a lot of ways it's the
bouncer of the solar system
it's the one that's like taking hits for
us because asteroids get
dumped in and comets are coming in and
what does jupiter do it takes a lot of
hits
sure it deflects some of them our way
mm-hmm let's not talk about that part
right but unless you want to but i do
but most of what it does is protect it's
potential protector so i'd really like
to see
if we find an object or the solar system
out there right that's what it says to
all the problems that they come in
like nope id includes what your
trajectory is right here
trajectory please right right no not any
happening
keep walking so i would not call it a
failed star i'd call it the bouncer of
the solar system
the most important of the planets for
earth to consider
right now so how much more mass would it
need
to for it to have ignited a core of
energy
or not even of course for it to not have
ignited a core of energy well
become the overachieving planet right so
the brown dwarf
regime uh is roughly the lower mass
bound that we
call is about 13 times the mass of
jupiter but that
not a great number that was a
traditional number though about a factor
of 10.
and right and the reason is because at
that mass
you can get heavy hydrogen burning or
deuterium burning
and so because that tended to be a
definitional thing
where either the difference between a
star and a brown dwarf
is hydrogen burning nuclear burning and
then it was kind of capped at the bottom
end of like well at about 13 jupiter
masses then
it's deuterium burning that stops and so
boom that was the definition and it's
terrible so the way to think about it is
just if jupiter had
more than 10 times its current mass it
would start entering the brown dwarf
regime
yeah it would be a massive okay but
something about jupiter however
that just would be proud i think is that
it is emitting more energy than it is
receiving from the sun
yes so it is a net energy generating
object
in this solar it's like a blue state
sorry that was that was very cool
i'll fill in those details after this
break when start talk continues
the world between planets and stars
my favorite thing to do on story blocks
is to see how much work it must
take to get all their stock videos
while i can just download them in
seconds just think what you'd have to do
to get footage of santa
you'd have to find reindeer you got to
fly to the north pole
mistik a cat for santa and once you
finally
found santa you ask him for a lot of
money
go surfing with the jolly man and then
sit him down
to get that shot with santa check out
the unlimited plan on story blocks for
all the 4k video your little heart
desires
links in the description that's
storyblocks.com
star talk we're back on star talk
cosmic queries the worlds between
planets and stars
and we have one of the world's experts
yes jackie ferry
one of my colleagues she's my colleague
right yes well while i'm sitting here i
can be her colleague
while i'm here yes exactly no we get
comedians here they're your colleagues
i get one of my people she's my
colleagues somehow i lose in this deal
so we were talking about jupiter as not
a failed star but an
overachieving planet but still it's a
factor of 10 in mass away from having
turned on as a star so that's still kind
of far away it's not kissing the door
you know kissing the boundary there
right factor 10. no yeah
it's a it's it's in squarely in though
we're totally comfortable calling it a
planet
object it'd have to be quite a bit more
massive before we
start to feel awkward there are other
systems there's one called
hr8799 it's the name of the star uh and
it has a name for the catalog out of
which they come yeah yeah
right and these stars also have multiple
names but that's the most popular of the
names
i often call that system that's the
catchiest name
hr 799 that's the most popular
so i sometimes call hr879 the brad pitt
of planetary systems that have been
directly imaged
because if you have a camera aka
coronagraph or an adaptive optics system
for a special camera for this yeah yeah
we point it at hr879
because it's so pretty
nice the system and you can image four
one two three four planets orbiting and
one fell swoop
yeah and i would highly recommend for
your
um for your brad pitt know this i have
said it so much i hope so
okay and that i'd like him to just feel
like the honor of
the brad pitt status of planetary
systems
hr799 he could just call himself the
hr879 of uh
i'm hollywood's hr 8799 baby switch it
up just so you know
just so point a camera so the year i was
the sexiest astrophysicist alive okay
this is 40 pounds ago by the way
um i love that we are now measuring
chronology in pounds
brad pitt was the cover as sexiest man
alive
beyond category nice to meet him had to
be in a category right in order
to but he had no category what year is
this
next time next question
oh that was great next question all
right so i have a question
personally that i i just i'm thinking
now and i just
i can't stop thinking about it as you
were talking about these formation
mechanisms
what i want to know is is it possible
to have those two formation mechanisms
happen simultaneously
so i'm sorry the three formation
mechanisms
happen simultaneously so that you have
that star
that's being surrounded by
a brown dwarf and planets
yes can that happen so you're asking a
question that basically got asked
at a seminar the other day i ask it all
the time and
the result would be uh is it possible
that you can form
a brown dwarf yeah what this thing is
that we call a brown dwarf these objects
that have
deuterium burning and they're formed
through the process of fragmentation of
a giant molecular cloud
and you can make that same kind of
object deuterium burning
through the accretion process or
gravitational fragmentation around a
star
right and so can you get
if you're going to count up all the
objects you would see
at a certain mass you would start to get
more of the object because you're
forming them
two different ways and so you would see
a higher number of objects popping out
as you get down to like
maybe it's at 10 jupiter masses maybe
it's at 12 maybe it's at four
whatever it is because you're doubling
down
on how you form the mechanism yes you
would double the number of double maybe
triple maybe quadruple or maybe just a
little bit more
but we're looking for this exact thing
for counting up the numbers we get
and then there's any signature
i take it back i take it back pretty
good pretty good
yes yes 100 this is all right cool
excellent so chuck this our final
segment we got to go into like lightning
round
let's move into our lightning round
okay go chuck well this is such a
fascination so jackie your answer has to
be
a sound bite we're testing your sound
bititude got it okay
ready all right go check okay uh this is
kristin davies and kristen says
i'm a seventh grade science teacher in
ohio and i asked my students for their
questions on the topic today
my students and i enjoy listening to
clean episodes of star talk
okay now you see why i'm reading
episodes that don't have chucking that's
what i'm saying thanks a lot kristin
i'm the one reading your question
christian just remember that uh during
our study times i listen to other
episodes of my commute to work
and that gets me pumped up so here's
what she says uh
from the student how many stars are in
the universe has anyone ever counted
them and is it possible
uh another student says can you turn a
planet into a star one and two questions
okay first question go
all right so number of stars in the
universe universe
that number's insane number of stars in
the galaxy we're gonna go with 200
billion probably and so then there's
billions and billions of galaxies
that's what i'm saying too too large for
me to give the exact number
second question can you turn a planet
into a star
awesome question people are trying to
figure this out unlikely because you
dump enough material onto it
it probably gets fatter and you probably
can't ignite
unless you do a gigantic dump from
something that happens
take a dump on a star
okay still clean answer still clean
fantastic but we can do a quick
jacket we can do the calculation yeah if
for the for the number of stars
if you if you just say our galaxy has
like 100 billion stars let's say
200. let's go 200 billion but it's
factor two between friends
yeah yeah sure okay so and to keep the
math simple 100 billion stars
okay and this somewhere between 10 and
100 billion galaxies in the observable
universe
so 100 billion times 100 billion
that's 10 to the
21st power okay there you go what do you
call that
that's uh one section sextillion that's
a sextillion six tillian that seems very
small
uh well let's do it so a billion is stay
with me
nine zeros is a billion right trillion
okay
count the zero just 12 10 right 12. okay
units three
zeros at a time because it would have
been 100 billion start again okay
so 12 trillion trillion 15
quadrillion quadrillion 18
quinton 21.
right yeah so that's what i'm saying
yeah yeah so about six two
but i'm saying when i say that seems
small i mean it seems small sexillion is
small to you
yeah no plus plus i mean it's big that's
a number i don't say because it's just
it's just too crazy i'm talking about
when you
from where we're starting i i think
because you said it's only 100 billion
in our own galaxy in our galaxy yeah
okay all right forget it then plus plus
plus if if there's not a sextillion
stars again then there's
two sextillion right at those numbers
these
factors that don't make a difference
they might want to get the sense of the
scale of this more than what you still
can't get this
but one other thing and not all galaxies
are our size they're so no there's
small ones there's collide galaxies that
have merged and come together but
another thing they asked about
counting the number of stars and there
is this survey called
the um it's a european survey it's
called gaia
and counting they have they're called
the billion star survey
1.7 billion stars and that's that's
that's
huge those are not extrapolated they're
actually counting
counting they've counted about measure
their distances how far away they are
it's the greatest map
that humans have ever produced 1.7
billion billion billion objects in a
catalog that's like a drop the mic
moment yeah i can't do that here okay
you did okay he did it
i was gonna say please don't let that
hit the ground
[Music]
excellent next okay keep it moving go
there we go all right this is from
twitter and this
is um
says this i think that's the name who
cares how do astronomers stop shot cares
i'm sorry
probably cares how do astronomers
study the atmospheres of brown dwarfs
and how do we even detect them yeah
that's exactly what i do for a living
yeah and the way that we detect it is
directly so that's the actual message
for a moment that you can do that for a
living yeah no it's not
that's a great thing to say just a
moment just a moment
oh let's all hold hands yes meditative
moments yeah
okay that's a wonderful thing that that
that you can do that for a living
yeah okay go yeah i also say the tagline
for astronomers though is unlocking the
secrets of the universe for a living
like that's a good tag line right
you know i mean sure studying the
atmosphere of brown dwarf sounds good
too
but unlocking the secrets of the
universe remember we're in lightning
round i know sorry
direct imaging is the technique that we
use okay
and i basically take a telescope i point
it directly at the object
for the most part i have to use infrared
instruments though okay so
a wavelength of light that you can't see
with your eye a wavelength that's a bit
longer than the
than the radiation that we all give off
the heat that we give off
uh and um i'll take it and i'll take the
light i pass it through a spectrograph
and i look at what it's made what what
is the chemical composition what kinds
of lines do i see and mostly it's
molecular features
molecules okay all right cool all right
excellent um
there we go let's go uh this is tomcat
thank you tom
tomcat wants to know this do brown
dwarfs have surfaces or are they just
balls of hot gas yeah that
is we're often asked this and there's no
surface for you to stand on similar with
jupiter and saturn
you're not going there and standing and
having a really nice time yeah
yeah no we call them gas giants yeah gas
giants and so brown dwarves are souped
up gas giants
okay very similar so there's no point
deep enough where it's dense enough that
you can call it a surface
there might be we don't know
could they have some sort of core
similar to jupiter or saturn which would
have some sort of core
very well it could have that we don't
know yet though
excellent this is
luigi luigi vane says this
how do we know what a planet is made
of and if it has an atmosphere
if it goes by how much light passes
through or by it so that sounds like
they're asking about the transit method
uh one of the ways that we detect
planets is by looking
at the planet pass in front of its host
star between
your eyeball and that host star and
there's there's lots of methods that
astronomers have developed to look at
the light of the star very very
carefully
and see if there's any change in it as
they are suspecting the transit is
happening you have to have the timing
down like smackdown
to when that transit is happening you
look right at the star and you can see
what it's made of
this is very complicated you see what
the atmosphere of the planet the
transiting planet is made of
right right through the light of the
host star it's a very complicated method
my preference just to re re-gauge us
back to brown dwarfs
is we draw upon what we do in
brown dwarf science since we directly
detect the atmospheres
we can guide any measurements that you
want to make when you're trying to
uh make detections oh so you have ground
truth of what the atmosphere might be
exactly
for those who are looking for the
transit in front of a much brighter star
in the background
we are a ground truth for transiting
planets
especially hot jupiters these objects
that are pretty close in that are like
jupiter
cool all right here we go actually we i
think we just ran out of time did we
really
we ran out of time oh yeah yeah i'm
sorry all right
that's sad so many questions i think we
should have we should have
put a few of those online and have
jackie answer them too oh that's a good
idea
yeah yeah yeah yeah well put in for that
it's amazing about i mean
people really are about brown dwarfs man
into what you get paid to do this for
for
living pretty good job pretty good job
all right jackie thanks for being on
star today it's not your first rodeo
with us
and so no well i've done all-stars with
chuck but this is the first time we've
been is it our first time
our first time yeah yeah oh so you so
you go way back
yeah yeah i'm like hr 80 okay
of course all right this brings this
episode of star talk to a close i thank
my
co-host chuck nice always my friend and
colleague jackie
clarity thanks for coming on and as
always
i bid you thanks to storyblocks for
sponsoring this episode of star talk
we know a lot of you like science and
that's why you listen to this podcast
so if you also like making science
videos
storyblocks has so much science stuff
they have chemical formulas to make you
look smart
scientists working in labs human anatomy
and more it doesn't stop there you've
seen us
use space video before and they also
have atomic stuff
and for some reason this scientist in a
bubble suit
make yourself look like a professional
filmmaker with storyblocks unlimited
plan
that's unlimited 4k royalty free stock
footage
they also have audio photo and video
templates
so what are you waiting for head to the
link in the description and get started
with storyblocks today
storyblocks.com star talk
you